it is time to hashtag make a scene at
the cosmopolitan of las vegas and you're
invited
to help the hotel celebrate their
10-year anniversary
with a special photo tour and cocktails
and
rocky is there live to tell us more hey
rocky
hey mercedes okay so this is one of my
favorite things in vegas it's kind of a
secret though so
make sure you're paying attention we're
at the chandelier bar at the
cosmopolitan of las vegas and they have
a special drink
that's not on the menu and it's called
the verbena so we're going to send it to
the mixologist rachel here to tell us
about it
hi kind of an asian inspired margarita
um has obviously some tequila that's
important
hello so great way to celebrate a decade
of mischief here yeah
tequila is always a good thing some
ginger syrup uh-huh
i'm gonna go on the other side and we
can't give you all the details about the
drink because it's their signature here
at the chandelier bar it's been around
since 2010
and i've heard they've sold upwards to a
million
already almost a million so i mean it's
clearly a fan favorite
yeah it's totally fan favorite so tell
people why it's so special though it's
not just tequila
it's not just drinks it's also flowers
look at this lamb
look at that they call them the buzz
button the bug
they come from the szechuan plant um
they are an alkaloid they actually open
up your
salivary glands and give you almost like
a a buzzing sensation
yeah and it opens up all of your taste
buds so when you're tasting the cocktail
you're getting
different nuances throughout your
experience how does it work so i want to
i want to show people
yes let me shake this up for you unless
you want to shake it yeah so while she's
taking i want to also tell you there is
a photo tour to celebrate the 10 years
here at the cosmopolitan as well
and all you have to do is text when you
get here i'm going to use my notes
so i get this right text hi rose that's
seven
six seven three and then you get a photo
tour entry to
the tour guide who's called lady of
mischief here
we're gonna leave she's gonna actually
take you to spot to spot
where you have some fun instagramable
moments i hope they're showing the
pictures here
so you not only have you not only get
the chandelier bar
and the beautiful all right but you also
get some fun posts for your social media
okay so what's the rule because you take
it you take a little bite
kind of swish it around in your mouth a
little bit yeah
taste that tastes like a regular
margarita yeah take a bite
kind of get it all over you don't want
one side to go numb and not the other
best tasting thing
afterwards drink it up wow
and then it gets a little spicy so it
changes the flavor oh yeah
they're so cool you guys have to come
down celebrate 10 years of mischief here
at the cosmopolitan
get the barbina at the chandelier bar
i've had that flower before and it
is crazy yeah have fun i can't wait to
check it back in with you
during the 4pm newscast rocky thank you
that flower just
opens everything up on your taste buds
all right let's take